[Music]
what is up what is good how you live in
how you feel in lef koe me an and I'm
here with Brian Westbrook number 36 as
we always are that's right man
Giants listen to us man they did you did
a podcast we put out I put out a clip
love us Pia you were like we need to do
this daniel Jones say qualm Barkley a
month ago I said daniel Jones gonna play
during week three and Shermer and mara
said alright they listen to the pocket
if they're smart men they are and they
also have obviously they have eyes and
they can see that something is are right
were you it didn't feel shocking to
anybody no I actually felt dumb because
I went a lie his record is 116 and 116
of course it's happening now yeah you
know that was if eli finished his career
116 and 117 oh man it felt obvious when
i heard that statistic you could have
made the argument that they should have
benched eli two years ago matter of fact
they did i mean you you so last year
tried to i'm watching him and i'm like
oh something's wrong with a lie and
there's nothing wrong with them arms a
little bit weaker can't move around in
the pocket the other part is the thing
that you do with young quarterbacks and
aging quarterbacks is surrounded with
talent yes they surrounded him with one
talented guy that's it and they got rid
of the other talented guy
so they got rid of LOL buckin jr. yeah
and they got sake want other than that
there's no talent no and that's a
concern especially when you have a
one-dimensional quarterback that stays
in the pocket and tries his best to
throw the ball high i will still stand
by the fact that i think Eli looked
better this year then he has the last
two years like I thought he came in in
the best shape I thought that he
actually made a few good throws on
Sunday yeah but all of his rival
receivers drop everything and the only
guy who really has a sake one but it's
been time to go this team needed to go
in another direction and I thought your
point you only have one chance to let
these two young guys grow together
yeah and now if I'm a Giants fan and my
team is going down to Tampa Bay and I
have Daniel Jones maybe doing a little
read option with say qualm Barkley and I
got Evan Engram at tight end I'm excited
to watch Sunday's game well giants since
Eli has been the quarterback there in
Tampa two and one and the last time they
play they lost was 2017 but it was one
of LA's best games two touchdowns no
interceptions 91 quarterback rating
almost 300 yards in the rain
Giants always play well in Tampa they in
the other two games they outscored on 56
to 18 right so I look at this team I
think that Todd Bowles is gonna be a
tough matchup for jumps very good coach
it's a it's a place where Devon white is
out there starting middle linebacker for
the Tampa Bay Bucs and they don't have a
good pass rusher you know who their best
pass rusher is it was a jpp and he's out
right now not playing because of his
accent in the offseason not the
fireworks he actually got into a car
accident so every offseason he's got
something but if it was jpp versus
Daniel Jones that headline would be
amazing I think that the Bucs are a good
defense but say Quan and Daniel Jones
can get something done well this is what
I think about the Bucs and I do think
that they're good defense however this
is a good thing for Daniel Jones yes we
know that Jameis Winston will throw the
ball to the other team so it's gonna
keep you in the game longer so instead
of saying hey I need Daniel Jones to
throw the ball 50 times a game just so
we can score points right you can say
okay we can live with more run plays and
I just wrote it down which is kind of
crazy to me
sacrum Barkley first two weeks 36
touches 29 runs 7 passes what that he's
caught to me he should be between every
week yeah you sure for this team yeah 23
and 28 touches per week which is kind of
crazy but this is the only weapon that
you have especially now you're bringing
his work in it doesn't have to be
between the tackles touches know if say
Kwan isn't getting seven eight targets
in the passing game screens little
shovel passes will you bring it Daniel
Jones he should get he should be
catching a ball four to seven times per
game I ever game Lee subscribe to the
fact that patch Shermer has been running
an offense for Daniel Jones
the entire preseason and the first two
weeks so that it's an easier adjustment
because their skill sets are wildly
different and I believe that Shermer was
asking Eli to do things that are more
easy for daniel Jones than him we're
gonna get into a lot we're gonna do more
of this where does Eli go historically
Hall of Fame is this the beginning of
the era of the black quarterback in the
NFL interesting conversation we're gonna
get to we will also want to talk about
the three big games of the week this
week but definitely Chiefs Ravens two to
no teams one team with definite Super
Bowl aspirations and the Chiefs so I
think those two I'm just gonna but
cheeps out a little bit a little behind
the back Chiefs that trick mahomes and
the Qi is my football little brother
okay love ya
the Ravens I am I believe that they're a
fan base that has no national voice
champion them yes because even Ray Lewis
is gonna come on there and be like now
when we played we went harder then they
go right now we have momentum that's the
Ray Lewis voice that's what he sounds
like
preacher voice but there's no one
nationally that's standing for the
Ravens well cuz my feel an obligation to
stand for the rainbow zero some
questions behind it ray well they
haven't they have been proven over time
that they can do it that's the big my
only one six they only went six and one
down the stretch last year went to the
playoffs
absolutely and like went into Kansas
City last year and it almost beat them
they did it differently last year they
did it with the running quarterback and
they can't maintain that and so now you
have Nomar Jackson coming in throwing
the football the question is can he
maintain as you can see it'll be a
little bit feisty first thing I want to
do though is we didn't get it last week
I want to make sure we do it this week
the LF GL the left go football gridiron
league the let's [ __ ] go fantasy
league where we got around like 1200
people playing okay our Commissioner
William ezel Saints kid here he is young
cute too he put together the whole thing
he's helping organize all of it and I
made him a deal you do that you get
about 45 seconds a week to give me an
update on the fantasy league
so let's check in really quick with my
man w GE to William ezel and see what's
going on the let's [ __ ] go League you
have Cam Newton Oh drew brees Ben
Roethlisberger Alshon Jeffery Sean
Jackson Quincy Newton MA
Sam Donald Tevin Coleman hunter
henri-michel Gallup Darius guys AJ Green
Joe Mixon Tyreke Hill and Nick Foles and
that's just the start of the list but
that's not even the craziest thing that
happened this week in fantasy we had not
one but two games decided by one passing
yard that's 0.04 points the smallest
increment possible I mean that that's
got to be incredibly tough to lose by
that margin and what has shaping up to
be it's gonna be a close one they share
just like those games and I wish the
best of luck to everyone except those
teams are undefeated you know who you
are and I believe that's a shot at me
Brian Westbrook that is the shadow cuz
I'm until you're undefeated hell yeah
that's impressive
my receivers are stacked well I love
making mad trades and I think people
just want to trade with me yeah so
they're making trades like I shipped
Sheamus and Crowder Devonta Freeman and
Godwin and I got juju and Vance McDonald
and then Ben got knocked down yeah but
the guy was like I just want to trade
right yes wanna make a trade okay hey I
just want to remember I just want to
remind you to game doesn't make a season
Baltimore Ravens Adam left Co two games
there's a very similar on the Lamar
Joshu game does it make it season
there's 2 of 16 oh you used to do
fantasy every Sunday every son do you do
any more fantasy at all professionally
yeah not you playing like are you on
camera anywhere do you no no no I I you
know what and don't give me like give me
the real I'll tell you this though going
into it
I didn't love it because you got to keep
up with a lot of different crap no it's
just I've always thought that
professional football players most of
them go fantasy I don't wanna deal with
this [ __ ] well not not only dead
sometimes it goes against your natural
instinct to say hey this team is better
so they're gonna just do this in which
you see with your eyes as a player
always translate in the fantasy world
yeah and so now you're like okay my eyes
are telling me that they're going to go
into this game they're gonna run it down
their throat but the fantasy people say
well they have this guy out and they
have that guy out and there's no way
they're gonna run the ball they're gonna
throw it I'm like yes this is what I'm
gonna do in low and behold they're
throwing the damn ball 35 times so is
that weird to you to be in a room with
people that have never played the game
and they're going they're talking about
target share and like
reception regressions and they're
talking about passing funnels this is
what they're doing they're looking at
their paper they don't they have been
watched and watch the gate any of the
games are going but they're going but
the amount of targets that Jameson
Crowder is getting so when you were
having those commerce analytics that's
what it is
did it frustrates you in the beginning
it frustrated me but it also gave me a
different way to view the game and so
the more and more I talked to him like
okay if if they had the ability to see
what I see
plus add in the analytics I'd really
that's what every front office in the
league is trying to do they want the
scouts to be able to say okay this
player is good because he can run he
could jump he could laterally move from
left to right but the numbers say that
he's better because of this that's what
every front office is trying to do
combine the two to figure out what's the
best move as a player and as an analyst
you're like well hold on I don't want to
go away from what my eyes are telling me
because it took me 25 30 years to
develop this yes but the numbers they
speak for themselves yeah so it's the
companies I've just always wondered to
be someone that truly can watch a game
and see things that other people can't
right and then to be in a room with
people that are deemed experts that has
to be jarring to the system it is John I
think the worst part about being a
fantasy analyst is that every question
you get is wholly personal to only the
person asking it if you go online and
someone says should I play Debose Samuel
or Delvin or devin Smith yeah no one
else gives a [ __ ] about that except for
that person but if somebody hits you up
and goes Browns - two and a half if you
give it answer anyone that had a
question you've helped them that's right
also football is a weird game and you're
gonna be wrong about predictions that
seem obvious all the time
week three last year the Buffalo Bills
were 17 point underdogs to the Minnesota
Vikings and they won yeah and I said
there's no chance in hell they were
gonna lose yeah and people called me an
idiot for weeks and really none of them
would have taken it and there's that
something about fantasy where you get
things wrong and people to get
football's awful predict football is
terrible because you'd never know what
happens you don't know what goes on in
the locker room you don't know if I'll
give you a perfect example in the past
weekend we talked about the Eagles but
who the heck would have guessed that
Dallas Goddard gets hurt in pregame and
DeSean Jackson John Jackson now Shawn in
and what all these guys get hurt in the
same game and they're asking about the
turf they're saying it's a growing it's
the ankle is the calf is the rib all
these different things and then if you
went on your show and said I like the
Eagles to win right they're gonna go be
you so huh no your judgments no good
anymore I can't predict about this how
about this I told everybody on Monday to
load up on in joke ooh prop bets well
yeah
Mosley's out at middle linebacker yeah
we got we got in joke ooh they're gonna
work the middle of the field huh gets a
concussion on the second drive he has
four catches on a year so on you buddy i
concussion like ii drive by two games
but somebody looked at me right after he
got hurt and was like what the [ __ ] left
co uh-huh and I go are you blaming me
for him getting a concussion
yes you sick [ __ ] yes yes that's how
people and they want you it's weird
because when you on these shows they are
counting okay he right yeah he's right
he's right that one time out of ten that
you're wrong uh you're the worst analyst
ever I can't believe you couldn't see
that nobody else saw it but you missed
it too
you know how unlike NBC or ESPN they do
they're like Fox and CBS they do the pic
shows and they show the records I think
it'll be really funny if every year
whoever got the worst relegate whoever
got the worst record was kicked off the
show can't even be there Terry Bradshaw
out of there I'm sorry you went 26 and
38 yeah we're removing you and we're
bringing in Brian West that's right
because he knows how to picks games and
obviously you don't and and but here's
the other thing if looks like you can
never pick games but you analyze it
perfectly people want to know what like
will why if you can analyze you can
break it down so well why can't you pick
the game I can't
you pick a winner I get DMS all the time
from people that say I love the way that
you break down a game it makes sense but
I also know when you make mistakes and
you go too much with your heart and
that's when I bet against you yeah
people will DM me and go I make so much
money off of you because you'll go on a
whole rant and go but I got a feeling
and I bet against you and I'm like can
you tell me so I can bet against myself
too I go I go I won four in Webster
right now any time he has a real big gut
feeling he bets the opposite way and
he's six for six this year I always my
initial feeling is I go if I go with my
gut and that's oftentimes wrong always
because I think you know what they have
to be better than Minnesota has to be
better than that they can't be they I'm
too good receiver they have a decent
quarterback in in a very good running
but they have to be better than that and
it's always wrong because my mind is
like there's no way there's no way to
lose three in a row it's it's a matchup
game where every week the Minnesota
Vikings might maybe the Packers are an
awful matchup for the Vikings but the
Vikings go and play the Lions it might
be a perfect perfect action and they
look like a completely different team
yeah also its export that because it's
such small amount of possessions
turnovers are such a big impute change
the game and it could be a tip ball well
that's what happened to the Falcons yeah
in the first game against the Vikings
punt punt block interception it changed
the whole course of the game yeah and
now they look terribly look like a
terrible football team they didn't look
much better last week against the Eagles
but they look absolutely terrible 28 to
12 in the first game against the Vikings
Vikings last week get beat up on so I
mean it's weird game man oh so it was a
weird game it's been a long game for Eli
as I said in the 232 games he's played
perfectly 116 116 the timing of the
benching it may okay to you or no I mean
the real answer is they should have cut
him before the season yes
and not spent 24 million dollars on his
contract and maybe because you knew you
were gonna build around daniel Jones
anyway use that money on other positions
that could have I think traditional
thought especially around first-round
talent just quarterbacks young
quarterbacks anyway is let them
sit for a little bit try to be like
Aaron Rodgers and Patrick Mahone's and
things like that let them sit to me you
can do that if you're Aaron Rodgers you
have Brett Favre in front you Patrick
touch from their homes had Alex Louie
play well that year that probably was
Alex miss best year almost in the NFL
I'm sure I've always never because he
was afraid of passion he has some but in
this case why would you sit daniel Jones
based on what you've seen of Elah these
last couple years to me I wasn't
impressed with Eli lash I hear probably
the best year in a long time forty two
hundred yards but it was some throws he
just missed I mean he could have had
five thousand yards if he hits half of
those throws we have one of the best
receivers in the game in Odell Beckham
jr. they didn't quite see eye to eye to
me
you give him 14 15 targets again and you
have to connect them on more than half
it's because I couldn't reach him he
couldn't get it
so my question didn't have strong enough
arm the big question around Eli is is he
a hall-of-famer two Super Bowl wins two
throws that will be remembered for the
history of time overall 500 quarterback
yep not great playoff success no other
than those two runs two MVPs who's two
times in Super Bowl MVP and I would
argue that Justin Tuck should have in
the Super Bowl MVP in one of those with
three sacks a your argument um but my
question for you is you faced him twice
a year mm-hmm you were in the locker
room with a defense that had a lot of
success against Eli yeah over the years
what was the prevailing conversations
about when it was Eli weak
well you guys are playing Eli what was
the defense like that week compared to
other weeks I think the thought I'm
gonna give you a comparison and this is
hard because this is a stream right at
this point if you had Eli versus Patrick
when Holmes Patrick Holmes he you know
that he can go win a game for you you
know that you give him the football
you're scared Drew Brees the better
quarterbacks you're scared of those guys
when you talk about a two-time Super
Bowl MVP has obviously two super old
trophies on his man so you're thinking
he could go win a game for you at any
time he's dangerous but you never really
got that feel from Eli was always like
this is Eli the question I was asking
was if they're gonna play a
I could see a Jeremiah Trotter and a
Dawkins and everybody going we need to
be on our peace that's right yeah and
when they were playing Eli I'm wondering
if it was the same preparation that's my
saying you always felt like it's just
Eli you obviously you always prepare for
every quarterback course but I think
that you're much more apt to work a
little bit harder give a little bit more
if it's drew Brees
because you know that if he gets going
it's gonna have some trouble it was
looser little bit easier I wouldn't even
want to say the word loser it was just a
different mindset you think you're going
to the game thinking you know what if we
could just contain everybody else we're
not worried as much about Eli and listen
to me he birthed the ego is a bunch of
times
sure at the same time when you just
think about them probably went ahead
Sean Peyton this is this is actually why
the question is is he a hall-of-famer
because when you think about it your
first reaction is no but then you start
looking at the numbers and you say oh he
plays 16 gears he has two MVP obviously
two Super Bowls you say well maybe
because in my mind when you talk about
Hall of Famers your first reaction
should be yep that's him Randy Moss Hall
of Famer Terrell Owens
Hall of Famer Eli let me look at the
numbers Big Ben Hall of Famer obvious
Brees Manning Favre all these guys
obvious Hall of Famers Eli's similar
numbers probably better in some cases
and I have them all here for you and
you're saying there's always a question
mark around Eli I do not believe that in
any year of his career when factoring in
yards quarterback rating and touchdowns
he was once a top-five quarterback I
could believe that
now if you look at his numbers this is
where it's interesting in BER helped put
him all together I'm very appreciative
it's a lot of Statistics I wanted to
compare Manning against his era of
quarterback okay let's do that
drew Brees Big Ben Phillip Rivers rivers
and brew and Roethlisberger were in his
traffic class Brees was two or three
years earlier he was the same draft
class as Mike Vick but I feel like those
four I'm not including Brady okay he's
out like yeah he's out like Brady is the
best yeah he's better than all of them
he's the he's the greatest quarterback
of all time I can agree he's not the
best quarter
all-time greatest yeah well yeah he's a
winner in terms of yards Eli Manning his
third hmm he's about wow 8 yards behind
Ben Roethlisberger for seventh all-time
rivers as a thought time he's about a
thousand behind that and Brees is about
twenty thousand ahead of all of them Kay
he's a different level so that that's
yeah I'm there that's for me it's
playing in a dome playing with Sean
Payton and then also I believe that of
those for Brees is the most cerebral of
all those quarterbacks probably the best
of picking a part of defense tell me if
you agree with this by the way of these
four Brees is the best leader slash
player of the position Ben
Roethlisberger is the most physically
gifted of all of them Vegas rivers I
feel like has the most is the most gamer
of all of them like he's never gonna
take a playoff and and Eli Manning I
don't know that's and that but do you
agree with that no yeah I absolutely but
that's the reason why everyone's the a
is all of him really but when I think
about obviously when I think about Brees
I agree with you cerebro he's a thinker
he knows where the ball goes before he
even he's also he was also a better
physical specimen than Eli he was
absolutely but smaller God but get very
accurate not a huge arm but gets a
downfield
it's obviously big been physical
specimen just a big man yeah
physical strong arm rocket for you know
the luncheon multiple times the biggest
thing and this is why you wonder this is
why you have the conversation about
Eli's because when you look at the
number just okay they're just okay
they're not terrible they're just okay
you throw those two Super Bowls in there
it's a different story to me if it's a
no-brainer if he doesn't have those two
Super Bowls let's just say he makes it
to the NFC Championship game both of
those years he's not a Hall of Famer no
doubt in my mind so let me add some more
context touchdowns Brees destroys all of
them rivers Roethlisberger Manning six
seventh eighth all-time but these are
accumulated stats yes because Eli has
been playing for 15 [ __ ] years but
when you start looking at win-loss which
we never want to give two quarterbacks
is whatever Roethlisberger
tenth most all-time wins with with
winning percentage rate on two out of
three games bends win at 667 breezes
second 150
six to 109 reverses third one nineteen
291 Manning 500 116 and 116 touchdown to
interception ratio breeze is seventh
all-time yeah with two point two two
rivers 13th all-time 2.09 pan
Roethlisberger a touchdown interception
ratio of 1.9 and Eli Manning a touchdown
interception ratio of 1.5 so a three to
two yeah so it when you talk about
thought process going into a game the
thought process playing Eli was always
if we get a little pressure on him he'll
give us a chance he'll chase out a
hall-of-famer he'll give us a chance
he'll give it well I'll tell you this
when we used to play against Favre we
knew that his arm could hurt us but
he'll give us a chance ok there it's a
different feeling is a different feeling
going into the game but there is
drinkers for sure but what I'm saying
though is Eli's not a risk taker in that
same way he just makes some terrible
decisions different types of mistakes
yeah Favre is going I think I can fit
this ball in between that's rather the
safety and the linebacker yeah and with
Eli you're going
we might get a duck in the third quarter
that no one can achieve if we're gonna
oppression we're gonna pressure with
this edge rusher
oh this cornerback blitz and he's gonna
see it and he's just gonna he's gonna
get rid of because he doesn't want to
get hit that's to always to knock on a
line he doesn't want to get hit that's
how you play for 16 seasons without
missing a doggone game because you don't
get hit smarter quarterback and blah
blah blah so you don't think he less
hall-of-famer I do think he's all in
fact I say all that just say I do think
he's all of Famer you went to Super
Bowls and you're the MVP of those Super
Bowls whether you believe those Super
Bowls were won by their defense or not
you believe Julian Edelman is a Hall of
Famer no Julian Edelman is gonna have
the same argument that Eli house I just
want a Super Bowl MVP well but this is
what you look at it for me for Juliet
enormous and the Seahawks play with you
play with the best quarterback ever you
play in the best system ever put on the
field with with with 53 guys on both
sides of the ball that that's just the
way it is and you play in that system
and you've been you've eaten in that
system it really it didn't matter it was
men with a Satori Brown weather as well
Welker it's the same guy doing the same
things putting up big time numbers he
just happened to be there the longest
and he's actually been very successful
there and they paid him that way and
he's done a great job and I would say
that Eli Manning played with at one time
the greatest pass rushing defensive
lineman out there that's ever played
with Michael Strahan in his prime and
most human urine is prime Justin Tuck
and Steve speck apt was over there first
time throwing using pass rushers as
defensive tackles now Bill Belichick
lost in the Super Bowl to Justin Tuck in
three sacks and then said I'm gonna
steal Michael Dennin thing and do the
same [ __ ] this right and so for me
like I you believe that Eli's a
hall-of-famer I do not I believe I have
always said that the people that go on
the Hall of Fame it should be impossible
to tell the story the NFL without them
and by that measure Eli Manning is a
hall-of-famer
I agree with you mm-hmm but in terms of
on that random week five Sunday yeah at
one o'clock and they're doing the
pregame show and they show the
quarterback throw in the ball I've never
seen elion been like that's a Hall of
Fame quarterback well ever here's an
I've seen I I'm still shocked Kurt
Warner got in right away yeah yeah do
you agree with he's on TV and I believe
that current forces has is going like
the next in about five years 2024 these
Hall of Fame discussions are gonna be
[ __ ] miserable that's right because
we're gonna be in an era of inflated
statistics and we're gonna be comparing
an Eli Manning to like a Ken Stabler you
can't and it's like they're not even the
same [ __ ] level you can but the
numbers right now are so out of whack
that we're never gonna be able to use
numbers anymore well here's another
question for you is it to me this would
be my argument he won Susu in their peak
better quarterback Cam Newton or Eli
Manning cam yeah in his peak yeah I
think there's no brain no chance of you
he'll never make but here's the thing
about Eli does who he won those Super
Bowls against yes slayer factor
absolutely
when you be the best quarterback ever
best coach best legacy to you stop 18
and no Patriots it's it's the best it's
the best team of the best quarterback in
the best coach of all of the Patriots
teams there was no team that inflicted
fear more than that 18 to no 18:1
Patriots team that's right and you're
the guy that beats them and really what
was the score the game 1714 it wasn't a
ha steal I really beat them or did that
offensive system all of a sudden get
shut down he was a he was the MVP I
that's all you could when you go back
and you look at these things the kids
gonna look at the numbers was he in fact
that the MVP goes down in history and
it's like uh who won MVP last year
Julian Edelman yeah it's like I don't
you could have given up honor the MVP in
that fun can give it to a lot of
different people but date that's the way
I go the MVP in last year's Super Bowl
should have been Stephon Gilmore for
what he did to the Rams slowed him down
but stopped there but we go
Edelman got the MVP and it's now I think
Edelman deserved by the numbers but like
that's the same way I feel about [ __ ]
alliance well a defensive player first
of all has to go over and above to be
even considered it is three sacks in the
Superbowl that that's MVP worthy that
that's Michael Bennett yeah that changes
the course of it yeah so you you're
putting him in there's so many more
people that are gonna be up there like
could be so much more desert well listen
the era of quarterbacks Eli Phillip
Rivers Big Ben Drew Brees all four of
them are going to be a Hall of Famers
all of them
and yes you add Tom Brady in there I
mean in this era of course is gonna be
interesting because Rivers does not have
the Super Bowls and rivers does not have
all that to lean on but I would say that
in that Marty Schottenheimer run mm-hmm
Philip Rivers when they were going like
14 and - every year that was some
dynamic but then you also the argument
against him as he's play with LT yes
well the greatest running backs of all
two-time Hall of Famers right look at
all the weapons he's had these last few
years these last couple years he had a
reason last year that based on talent he
should have been in Super Bowl I think
it's good based on timers to get in
that's the question here's another
question I'd rather have rivers in
healing this goes back
to our hometown team because I think
it's gonna be a big time push for number
five this year to get into the Hall of
Fame which Hall of Fame the team's Hall
of Fame there's gonna be a push these
next couple years for Don to get into
the Hall of Fame
there will be do you believe that my
name's all a favor I think you're more
of a Hall of Famers I'm so I'm so biased
I'm just because III let me say that
again
I'm so more of a Hall of Fame I
appreciate that I I think Donavan
numbers are we are we gonna hang out
Donovan ever because I'll shut the [ __ ]
up if he will not the commode he's in
New York every now and they will come on
absolutely so you can't say whatever
then there's no no no no because here's
the truth because if he starts coming on
and I start counting and becoming
friends with downing am I have to bring
the same energy but it's out of respect
yeah I still appreciate what he did I
think he's a Hall of Famer I think he is
I think that in his time period and you
have to listen you also have to factor
in the running number which he tried to
stop later on in his career which I
think was a huge mistake
but you have to factor in what he was
going on at the time period what Andy
asked him to do and because I'm super
bundle wide receiver that's career I'm
terrible to ask the question fact that
he's been to four straight NFC
championship games he took a team that
was three and thirteen and to April 11
in five perennial playoff team I'm
buying some Eagles were a laughing stock
of the league and they were the
Superbowl pick for Sports Illustrated
almost Dan every every year the 2000 and
it was done and then a bunch of guys on
the offense when you saw Nelson Aguilar
short arm did you have Todd Pinkston
flashbacks and I love Pinkston you know
I heard a new Nelson said Nelson said
that he lost it in a new light somebody
kind of prompted him with that though
someone said that's frustrating that's
what once said I wanted the finesse
inhaler apparently a reporter said did
you lose the ball on the lights and he
said yes and then paused and said but
that's not an excuse I should have
caught the ball well no that's not being
prompted that's like I already have an
excuse in my head and that's probably
gonna work
you dropped the doggone ball the balls
in your sight you have a chance to win
the game now unless I think Nelson is
talented I think
up to this point in his career he hasn't
even touched the surface of his house so
you think you believe that donovan
mcnabb is a better quarterback than Eli
Manning and that if you had to put but
one in the Hall of Fame you would pick
Donovan I just want to get that on the
record
oh man this you've already said that you
believe that Eli Manning is a whole
thing Eli's a Hall of Fame know what I'm
saying I would make the argument that
Donovan is a Hall of Famer too
and I know a lot of people she could
only put in one who would you put in you
gotta go Eli yes to the Super Bowls I
mean I think Super Bowls matter he's the
MVP of the Super Bowl twice did you know
we need to do you know well should go
next year trend over let's put him in
that's not the same he wasn't MVP that
defense was the MVP trent wasn't the NBC
nick foles gonna be a hall-of-famer no
he's not no Super Bowl MVP no what a
great a statistical CD that's all time
twenty said you just can't have a Super
Bowl MVP you just can't win a Super Bowl
you have to have the numbers it's a
combination of different things the
numbers the longevity Eli obviously has
it it doesn't hurt that he's a Manning
that doesn't hurt so would you rather
have and this is it playing to you
because if you're running back to would
you rather have a Terrell Davis career
where you play for six years but you're
a ball of fire yeah and like four of
your years are like 1,500 yards or more
or would you rather have an Eli career
where for 15 years and I'm not including
money I'm just talking about like the
respect that you have for your own
career right we're in Eli career it's 15
years of b-level football with
occasional moments of solid I I want
because they both have two Super Bowls
right yeah I want to have if I could
have a prime of let's say five years
where I was the best in the game I'll
take that and that was what sir all
Davis was that's exactly it was and
opposed maybe three or four but opposed
to 16 years of me being an average 15 16
years and meet me hours I'll take the
five years of me being the best in the
game because when you think about it
when people come up to you when kids
recognize that your peers they're saying
I remember I remember my first Pro Bowl
and I was pretty doggone good my first
year I went to the Pro Bowl right 2005
2001 2005 I caught a lot of balls
you know ran we know we were winning all
the other things I'm at the bar and
LaDainian comes over and to this point
like for me I went to a small school so
I didn't I didn't play against any of
these guys I didn't know any of these
guys here a very similar style to
LaDainian similar size he went to TCU it
was amazing I'm sitting there and I'm
looking I'm like now when I go over
there and I'm not I just wasn't at the
time I just wasn't I'm like if he wants
to talk to me I'll let him talk to me he
walks over and I'm like I'm like what's
up names like nah I respect your game so
much i watch all of your tape but not
obviously I watch all of his tapes
because he was the best back in Italy at
the time I watch what you do I loved
whether using on these routes it to me
it was touching like the best in the
game or says respected what I've done to
me that what that was awesome to me when
you are the best in the game that says
something when you just average Peter
you do be average for a long time people
like that but we need the best at
something people respect you in a
different level to me being the best for
five six years is way better than having
a 16-year career we're taken away please
tell me that that LaDainian conversation
turned into you guys are in Hawaii at
some beach bar and you get around a Don
Julio and then you and LaDainian
Tomlinson heaven no but it was a lot of
drinking going on at the pride here
against I hear it used to go down at the
all the way go down yes yes I mean Tom
about 14 15 years ago it went down and
it was it was them now everybody don't
give your room number out all that other
stuff because you have a what what
happens
you give your room number out you
sitting at the bar it was only the
players the players in the family you
get I get my room number to you so
they're like hey what remembering you're
like 1209 that's right and then the next
all the rounds all week long for their
young ki the first time guys are on you
and you don't have any idea know you
have for you until it didn't because I
didn't stay at the bar very long I
someone schooled me to it you were like
the people who told you who told you one
of these probably one of the older guys
probably be miss one product don't you
all the old guys that was great friends
with so they told me if you say at the
bar just be prepared to use your little
your little Pro Bowl money on paying a
bar tab do you know anyone that that
actually happened to not that I can
remember but I've heard a bunch of crazy
stories from
two different guys like you I used all
my little $30,000 on a bar tab for tall
the Pro Bowlers so back then it was
probably exciting and invited to the Pro
Bowl excite absolutely I mean that's the
pinnacle of your career if you're an
average season and a few years ago
Trevor Simeon turned down a Pro Bowl in
my Trevor he's made a huge mistake
because there's never
he'll never never get back to their
level ever again that's where the Pro
Bowls call net like well it's also it
was in Orlando now yeah you know the Pro
Bowl first of all it was big time you go
to Hawaii which was an attractive tie is
amazing I've never been you go to Hawaii
which is attractive you're hanging out
with the best players in the world yeah
and really you go to practice my year
I'm sorry I think Seattle was a coach
and went year the Falcons was a coach
right and Jim Mora yeah and he was just
like listen we're gonna practice about
45 minutes
and so it was probably just as long to
get to the practice field as it was oh I
bet you Andy was the Pro Bowl coach for
four years in a row cuz he kept losing
in the championship yeah yeah yeah he
was I bet you after a while you guys
were like yo man I'm [ __ ] tired of ye
well I think Andy was I mean of course
you want to make it to the toys yes with
Hawaiian shirts cuz he practically
always I think that I think in his mind
those shirts make him look smaller but
he always has those tiger in his Tommy
Bahama shirts on all the time I'm
worried about his ankle circulation he
was always very shorts when it's like 8
degrees that's his thing that's his
thing he said your legs don't get cold
he would always tell me that your legs
don't get cold we could practice outside
but just put a hoodie your legs won't
get cold I'm like coach your no no your
legs yours don't get ghost ankle right
the rest of us always had these socks on
and then every he'll wear these socks
all day long and then in the meetings at
night time is gonna training camp can we
have flip-flops woman you always would
see the imprint because you're probably
wearing compression socks I don't know
what they were but they were they were
big I love a dreary low you're not I
used to watch I mean oh my hey we used
to study Antony such a good dude great
coach anymore no [ __ ] say it
he's amazing no he's amazing you were
but he would do all he does funny stuff
all the time I cry about things that he
doesn't want other people to see like
Andy was all about especially with the
media it's it's I'm not gonna give you
who I am I'm just gonna tell you what
you want what I want you to know them
that's it
but when you talk to him one-on-one this
is why everyone loves them they he'll
talk about your family I want to know
what you and RINO observed well give me
a taste okay I'll give you a sample so
he will come into the meeting he was
organized he would have cue cards and
say he would say listen first meeting
I'm only going to talk about these
things in a cue card if I had to talk
about things on the back I'm talking too
long and so one day hey that's so self
illegals cue card and damn if he didn't
have words on the back and so
everybody's like hey hey hey you told us
you weren't gonna talk that long and he
was like well I just got it you know he
just you know it's Andy just a funny do
you gotta be there around him yeah great
coach great coach because very organized
home so Kelsey have told me that playing
for Annie Reed has made it so much more
fun and they've told me that like it's
there they're all very appreciative of
the situation they're in which is the
reason why I have such high expectations
for Pat is because Kelsey you know he
witnessed when you don't have the best
quarterback there and you can't make all
the throws that's right and so he is so
thankful Firma Holmes yeah and mahomes
because I think his dad played he knows
that you don't always get a tight end
like Kelsey that you can bond with right
away but he also knows that we don't get
a guy like Andy that's right and I think
they've kind of talked to enough guys in
the league where they're like not every
coaches like this but this is this is
what Andy has always wanted a
quarterback that has the arm strength of
Donovan McNabb can run around similar to
Donovan but he is he understands a game
in a different way yes he takes the game
to the next level he's willing to take
and make those those throws similar to
Brett Favre I don't know if he should be
here but he got it in there good good
throw good he's always to me he had a
patch of our homes
embodies everything that Andy always
wanted to run the offense the way that
he wanted to you add in a bunch of
talent to speed guys around them and now
you have Andy Reese and I can just
basically do anything on this big menu a
place I can do any of these things and
it's gonna be successful because of the
guy behind
you know what's interesting is I think
about my homes and because I'm homes are
such a gamer if he throws an
interception he's not gonna let that sit
in his head no he's coming out the next
time going and that was one of my issues
with Donovan over the years was I felt
like if he made a mistake it turned into
people are gonna talk about that mistake
I can't make a mistake again I kind of
felt Donovan was always judged on a
sliding scale like it was never good
enough in there's part of me that
believes it was a black quarterback
thing or there was part of me that
believes that it was a Philly thing and
the fans just didn't love him which they
still don't love him which bothers my
mind right now but I just think that
Donovan was always graded differently
than everyone I think it's a little bit
the way in the early 22 like late 2000s
early 2010s that Andy Dalton was judged
I think it's a little bit the way that
we were with the Colts for a little bit
when you have repetitive failures in the
playoffs the regular season doesn't
matter anymore
like that like for an adult and it was
like we know you're gonna be a ten and
six quarterbacking to be great but like
you always lose in the playoff and so
Donovan it became all we care about is
the playoffs and so it all of the the
regular season for touchdowns against
Arizona on a broken leg it turned into
well that's regular season yeah and it
becomes unfair it does I just had a
thought to flash him ahead we're talking
about Hall of Fame quarterbacks and I
don't have the number you got the
numbers there Jim Kelly right he's a
Hall of Famer yeah no brainer yeah I
never won a Super Bowl
no before he was there four times he did
go to four Super Bowls though yeah
that's meaningful but winning would be
nice of course
same thing with Thurman Thomas he was a
ground Brittany he was a he was the best
in the game yeah one of the top two in
the game at the time yeah HEIs a Jim
Kelly was a top guy in the game too
yeah Donovan was a top quarterback he
was a top-five quarterback he definitely
most of his career I think mm so when
they went six and ten or they went they
went three or thirteen I believe to five
and eleven then to six and three
thirteen he was out of the team that's
what allowed them the giraffe that I
mean AB they went five and 11 he played
like six key
that next year I believe he was number
two in MVP voting behind Marshall Falcor
and then after that Donna McNabb was a
top five top seven quarterback for like
the next five years absolutely I think
when you judge quarterbacks to have me
other than that was better than Eli
Manning yes same same way is camp you
could never really get a great gauge on
cam because he has so many rushing
people how you look now we go oh we did
that with Kelvin Benjamin yeah but
here's a jericho cochran people look at
my career and I don't and I'm not saying
that I'm a Hall of Fame play because I
think Hall of Fame is that you have to
be great I'm jumping into this next yeah
you have to if you have to do it from
longevity right but when they looked at
me as a running back they will always
look well your running back where's your
running stats what my gain was
predicated on running and catch ever
told you my NFL Network story now I
intern at the NFL Network in 2007 and
they would I worked in the features
Department and they would say come up
with any kind of topic that you want to
do and I said I believe that Brian
Westbrook is a tough I've run it back in
the NFL and I put together a whole doc
about how if you stop looking at rushing
yards yeah because they weren't doing
this in 2011 if you start looking at
total yards and yards per catch and
combine them at yards per play from
scrimmage Brian Westbrook has been neck
and neck with LaDainian Tomlinson for
the last five years and my guy who's now
King Josiah on Twitter yeah and he's
going viral all the time he was my
producer and me and and he said that he
goes bro I've never seen anybody do this
[ __ ] I go I'm telling you Brian
Westbrook it's a [ __ ] monster well
that's the same thing they never with
Cam and I tried though he's running Cory
I appreciate that yeah I guess it Mike's
what do you have on today - that's cute
I feel like you took a shot at me after
defeating on say pick that out I
appreciate that know the same person
that picked out your do you like that
yeah I love bizarre what do you picked
it this is our color that is what my
point is this rushing quarterbacks
always get that shot I know but you're
right running quarterback sweet when it
comes to the debate we never bring up
that's you you can't wait but you should
but we're gonna have to now because I
believe that we and I'm seeing a lot of
people talking about online
people are calling this the year of the
black quarterback okay I am gonna argue
that this is the beginning of the era of
the black quarterback mm-hmm everyone's
looking right now that if you look at
the top of the statistical charts you're
gonna see Lamar Jackson you're gonna see
Patrick mahomes you're gonna see dak
Prescott you're gonna see Russell Wilson
through the top four high booty and it's
very interesting that in the first two
weeks these four guys are skyrocketing
and we're losing big Ben Drew Brees and
Eli Manning all Oder quarterbacks you're
right that was their era but
simultaneously we're ending that one era
and we're entering now the era of the
black quarterback yeah and the thing is
is they all had the same [ __ ]
question except for Russell can they
throw can they throw Lamar is showing it
yep dak is showing it Patrick we've
never worried about this at all we knew
that you could yes but I believe we're
entering that era now well I think it's
gonna be beautiful I think it's gonna be
a great era but I also think that
college football plays a big-time part
in this to spread mentality bred
mentality get an athlete understand
armory that can do absolutely that can
do anything and and in as these guys
evolved Lamar Jackson great great great
runner especially Louie Billy threw the
ball a little bit but you know how he's
had a beautiful ball was know exactly it
wasn't always accurate but now he's
starting to learn okay if I can get this
passing thing down that takes my team
from here to here it takes me as a as a
quarterback from here to here and I
think coaches the same way that
Kingsbury has said well this is a the
future of the league well of course it
is if you can find a way to get an
athletic guy to throw in the same level
as Peyton Manning or Drew Brees or
someone else that doesn't have that
ability then as an office your PlayBook
opens up much much wider in a defense
you're saying okay how do we stop this
thing you got to stop their running back
they got a big-time receiver they got a
big-time tied in oh the quarterback can
throw the ball in any place he can get
the ball to any place on the field and
we got a watch of running it's almost
indefensible that's why I would think
that Clint Kingsbury wants this to be
the future of the league because he they
invested heavily in a guy
that can do just that this is why I'm so
excited for years we watched athletic
black quarterbacks play in the league
and get tried to put a square peg in a
round hole when it came to offenses
Michael Vick
had Jim Mora jr. we look at that now and
go oh I wonder why that didn't work
yeah Vince young they tried to put him
into a bunch of different systems that
weren't made for him right I look at
these young quarterbacks now and I see
the offense of minds that are with them
and I have a lot of hope
Patrick Moe Holmes has a refined Andy
Reid that's right
I look at Lamar Jackson it let me say
this it wasn't it's no I don't think
he's any mistake that Andy Reid is
getting the best out of himself in his
quarterback after he's had two
quarterbacks Donovan and an Vick and now
it's like refined that's right I look at
this is interesting
Lamar Jackson has Greg Roman Greg Roman
gave Colin Kaepernick his best years and
then Taylor that's right Tyrod Taylor to
Rod Taylor and so now he's more refined
and is and neither of them are putting
those guys in a situation dak Prescott
everyone's over the moon right now about
their offensive coordinator in Dallas
the young guy whose name I'm coming more
Kellen more yeah and they've built the
system around him yeah and Russell
Wilson what they've been I mean Russell
Wilson has overcome no matter who the
offensive coordinator is Darrell Bevell
or anybody but it's a system that goes
with him and I felt like in the 90s and
the 2000s it was like we know that you
can run but you still need to run my
brand of football yeah be a boxer built
around these well it and Cuyler Murray
has Kliff Kingsbury and the whole system
is made for a guy like caliber offensive
teams and coaches have brought in their
mindset oh we don't have to always do a
seven-step drop we actually get on a
roll them out a little bit get them on
an edge how many times they go Vic but
Ken Vick be a pocket passer yeah we
don't need them to we don't need me so
fact in fact I watched Nick Foles
in a Super Bowl against the Patriots use
a read option and we all know that
Nicky's ain't running anywhere and it
worked
imagine if Vick and all these guys
we're in the Erica and Vince Young where
the read option was lower my goodness
the the my offensive coordinator you
know back in the day and I go back to
Donovan because I think one of his
biggest things was that he wanted to be
wanted to be considered a great
quarterback in the mindset
he never said this but I always believed
it was true the mindset was the only way
that I could be considered a great is to
do it the same way and it's Payton in
Tom Brady right and Brees and really
what you would say is the the only way
that I think I can be great is to do it
the same way as the white quarterbacks
and the truth is is that he had a skill
set as armed wise strong as any of those
quarterbacks but he had a skill set that
none of them had and that was ability to
run and he would get an open space and
do that crazy move she was hella
shouldn't joke anybody but suit
everybody he had that so safe but in his
mind he was like I wouldn't be to
consider too great so he wanted to
lessen that ability which is always
crazy it was all [ __ ] rush limbaugh
yeah I I subscribed to that theory to
this day ESPN implied employed Rush
Limbaugh went on TV and said the reason
we are rooting for Donovan is we are
rooting for the black quarterback to
succeed
and I think Donovan more than anybody
lives apart and he took it to heart and
he said I'm gonna show them that I can
throw it's right our former my former
coworker Josh vendrick now works in
overtime they're about to start a
project with Deion Sanders and his son
uh-huh and he told me the other day that
Deion Sanders son is playing quarterback
really and Deion is telling his son you
are never going to scramble we are never
going to put any film on tape before you
go to college or anything of you running
because I don't want anyone to even
think of you as an athlete we know that
you're an athlete we know that when push
comes to shove you're gonna run but
right now I don't want anyone to put ATH
next to you when you go to college I
don't want anyone to go what if he could
run and pass it and or catch and all
that yeah and and I cook at those a
please move from quarterback to ever see
his because they go they go we'll
recruit them but let's also recruit this
other pocket quarterback because maybe
we can get them both of the field and so
for me I look at is not as whether it's
the right
or it's the wrong decision I look at his
Wow
Dion has seen this from the media
perspective in the player perspective so
long that he knows I need to do this so
that other people there I won't want
that effect so I'm not going to give
them the cause in a mindset that you
can't ever show athletic ability or else
you'll never be seen as a runt as a
quarterback
whereas when carson wentz can run yeah
and luck can run can we go
that's a nice tool in the tool box it
shows where we are as a society that we
still are overcoming this that it's not
it doesn't have to just be black
quarterback gets a quarterback that
happens to be black we're not there yet
I wonder in askance is a pocket
quarterback yes and very popular media
members assume that he can run I don't
know that he can I mean I don't you
can't I think he has even a Smith went
on and said he's a running quarterback
he's nice he I covered Teddy Bridgewater
I covered Teddy Bridgewater for all
three years at Louisville and when he
was going to the draft I'm doing
national radio interviews where people
go we know that Teddy can run and I'd
have to jump in and go no Teddy cannot
write that's not his thing but the
reason is is ESPN because he's black
that's why but ESPN are the three clips
they would put on TV him running two of
them would be him running and I'm like
you're controlling the narratives by the
clips you put on TV it's wild I wonder
if Dion's view would be different in a
couple years after you see the success
that Kyler could potentially have Lamar
Jackson do you know many rushing Hertz
calimary has thus far not very many 12
yeah probably not very many which
blowing people's minds right now yeah
and they're still having success you
know what's weird because if you're in a
defense you're saying he has a great arm
300 almost 350 yards last week but watch
out for him running and he hasn't done
it yet he hasn't even put it off him yet
but you your mind it has to happen at
some point I absolutely agree with you
we were having this discussion and I had
this realization the other day that
Russell Wilson might be the greatest
black quarterback of all time
and when I said it to you mhm immediate
no no you were like a [ __ ] out of here
baby and then we started talking about
it yeah it's a little crazy
so again
salute to Ingmar Abers have her went in
found some information currently of all
quarterbacks not just those that are
african-american
Russell Wilson has the second highest
passer rating of all time 100 point 9
you wanted people don't know anymore
found dak Prescott his third all-time 98
why is that include this year this
season okay when you start comparing him
to the other great black quarterbacks of
all time who are the names that pops
into your head right away when this
first came up Doug Williams okay Randall
yep Warren Moon of course Vick
yeah Donovan those are the names that
come up that's five yeah so of those see
McNair seeming narrative Steven there
for sure Bonner but when you start
looking at them Warren Moon is
interesting because he played six years
in the Canadian Football League's
he won five Grey Cups put a big time
yard big time numbers and ran the ball a
lot and when you look at his numbers now
he's still up there even not playing six
like passing yards all time of Moon
McNabb Newton Wilson and Vick warmoon
has over 49,000 which is tenth all-time
right so he's tenth all-time and he
played six years in the CFL mm-hm
McNabb is second out of those guys 25th
most all-time then Cam Newton Russell
Wilson's right there then Mike Vick Cam
Newton's right there huh Cam Newton has
29,000 Russell Wilson has 26,000 Vick
finished with 22,000 really so it makes
you kind of realize from that Vick is
not in this discussion now it also makes
me kind of think that cam is a little
bit better passer they're not probably
give him credit for touchdowns moon had
14th all-time McNabb had 30 it has 30th
all-time
Wilson's at 42nd all-time and he's got
about 19 more than Cam Newton and Vick
is fickle he had 133 touch I was
anything
no how's this thing no let's do win-loss
okay and win percentage Warren moons
record in the NFL 102 and 101 you think
about the Houston oiler teams in the
early 90s never they were beaten a lot
of teams but they were all over the
place yeah
michael vick 61 and 51 okay
Cam Newton 68 and 55 okay McNabb 98 and
62 and I'm not saying that's a good
record 600 yeah so out of 10 games he's
winning six Russell Wilson
ninth best all-time 68% winning
percentage 77-36 now I would say out of
all those teams he has the best coach in
Pete Carroll and he probably had other
than some of those years with McNabb the
best defenses to I mean Russell Wilson
early in his career much like Big Ben
came in he came in with the legion of
boom
Richard Sherman kam chancellor alright
decent unbelievable and I would say also
that much like Big Ben and Tom Brady
early in his career they were and and
you know what and Donovan team's carried
by their defenses I think that your
offense came in in around 2005 2006 and
they were the leading of the team but
early on it was trot and Vincent and
Dawkins and Taylor and and then when you
became a thing but if you really think
about it the core of your team was you
LJ Smith right and then hopefully
Pinkston thrash make again right
you know I thinking about it and I think
the other part about this Seattle deal
with Russell Wilson is that they have a
big time running game I mean their
running game Sean Lynch was amazing yeah
you have to think about how many times
Russell Wilson was actually throwing the
football 25 times a game 20 to 23 times
the game and he was absolutely accurate
big-time throws down the field two guys
wide open because they're all the
defense was like eight put nine guys in
a box try to stop Marshawn Russell
Wilson in terms of touchdown to
interception ratio impressive I'm sure
second all-time of course Corey 0.19 201
263 Warren Moon 1.25 we're like yeah
even well but you're right that the
hardest the thing about Russell Wilson
is Russell Wilson's gonna have longevity
yes and he's gonna mass more and more
statistics and you know what he has that
no one else has Super Bowl ring that's
important
Doug Williams really on the black
quarterback list Doug Williams is really
the only one other than
Russell Wilson and then you throw in
some of these young guys we'll talk
about them later but I think when I
think of the black quarterback so many
weren't given opportunity so let's start
there there are so many great athletes
that played that were black and played
quarterback that were never given the
opportunity so that's why the
discrepancy in numbers there recently
things have gotten better but Russell
Wilson smart athletic he can run when he
wants to
he's an accurate passer he can he's a
leader in a different way I think the
guys look at him a little bit different
for whatever reason but you talk about
Super Bowl winner winning quarterback
you got to go you got a you have to talk
about Russell Wilson he I think he is
the best black quarterback that we've
seen I you know again I'm just wild to
say because I don't think anyone has
ever thought this before or really put
any time to it and the other thing is
too is it's the discussion about Russell
Wilson's blackness that's what makes it
so interesting would you put them in the
top ten of quarterbacks in the in the
last 20 years of football Oh is he in
the top ten looks like from 2002 now 19
years top ten okay so then you're in the
breeze the Big Bend yeah your invar goes
in there for Laureate
Roger landing both Manning's Peyton I'm
not putting Eli above them Brady of
course thank youing burn-off he's in top
ten there he's he's French top ten
the thing is to though is all those guys
we've seen the 15 years yes with Russell
that we're at about seven so the thing
is is I think Russell is on a better
trajectory than any of them if he puts
another swing so wild to me is is last
year he lost the legion of boom and I
said they're not making the playoffs and
they forget got there that's right this
year they got rid of Doug Baldwin and a
few other people and their best receiver
is Tyler Lockett and then a rookie and
DK Metcalfe and a bunch of other guys
and there he's [ __ ] doing it again so
I'm reaching a point with him where I go
I know you've had Pete Carroll but now
we're starting to see everything changed
around you and nothing's chopping off
and you're still the same here he's on
the same trajectory and I think Russell
Wilson's gonna go and I know you kind of
like jumped past it though but the
interesting thing about Russell Wilson
is early on when they won don't forget
that Golden Tate was calling him out in
front of locker room and everybody was
saying that he's a company man and we
know the whole what comes with that and
and every I'm jokingly call him Russell
Wilson because now he's with Sierra and
he's getting his hair braided on
Instagram the whole discussion about
Russell Wilson as a black quarterback is
interesting to me because I think early
on that defense was not even discussing
him like that it was it was a weird
dynamic with Russell for a few years
because they didn't see him as that or
wide let me also state this has a white
guy bringing this up it's a very weird
thing for me to do is it well I just
think in the national discourse it's not
some that white people as far as his
blackness every how black it's not it's
not my place to discuss blackness and I
want to say that I think I think
something that's been talked about since
well that's a crazy concept up and it's
no black man woman child should have to
prove they're bright and clever and not
every black child his group grew up in
the hood get over smoking weed that
doesn't happen everyone there's some
affluent black people too yes right and
they raise their kids according to where
they live with things like that too so I
don't that was wrong for his teammates
to ever bring that out yes I mean I
think you can make jokes and that's what
that's what the locker rooms for you
make jokes you say all types of crazy
things that's nothing that should have
ever got outside of that locker
yeah period it's a it's just interesting
because in the end I believe Russell
Wilson was gonna go down as the greatest
black quarterback of all time I think he
I mean if we're talking about him in
that whole context right now yeah he has
another ten years of football that if he
happens to win a Super Bowl my only
thing about him now is and this is sort
of what we're seeing with player
entitlement Andrew Luck mm-hmm baseball
backgrounds yep I mean Russell Wilson
every offseason go thankless the Yankees
same thing and you know what I would see
if I went to the Yankees I'd see a bunch
of professional athletes with all
guaranteed contract yeah that don't have
to worry about brain injury right and
now I have Russell Wilson I don't know
Russell Wilson
you know just signed 150 million dollars
wherever it was
these guys now they might not need to
keep going like I could see Russell
Wilson after a few more years being like
I want to go try something else really
like go play baseball
I'm curious weren't curious about the
really well-paid players that put
themselves in harm's way and I'm just
seeing Jalen Ramsay get me out of here
I'm seeing Antonio Brown and I'm getting
texts from people go man they're trying
to go down that NBA route I'm just
seeing a lot of NFL players have that
realization I don't need this especially
if I got the bags well I look at Russell
in a different vein than all of those
guys because I think that even when you
talk about Andrew Luck Andrew Luck got
beat up for however many scenes he was
in the league except for last year he
got beat up Russell Russell God he got
hit a little bit but it was not the same
way and it's a different fact that
Russell went through all those years
with that offensive line being that bad
they were bad yeah absolutely so they
were bad I just think that Russell he's
so smart he's a great leader I think
that he'll play as long as you want I
don't know that baseball is really an
option for guys know as I think maybe he
says hey I got enough money I want to go
enjoy my wife is gonna make however much
money should make the other thing in I'm
just gonna continue to join you but Tom
Brady could have said that Tom Brady
could have said that I think Russell
Wilson has the same type of passion and
drive as Tom Brady I want to do it until
I can't do it anymore and to me and I
don't know either one of them I believe
that his wife will push him to do it hey
if you want to go make 20 million bucks
20 35 million bucks for the next ten
years do that it will enjoy when when
you're 40 cool you got another 50 years
of leave live I know my wife would say
that no no no no I know your knees hurt
go back to practice make your 29 bucks
and I'll talk to you in another couple
years will vacation in that is the big
topic though also is players seemingly
having more control and I think it's
more of a story because people are
getting upset with it and why are they
getting upset because it's not Eli
Manning coming in and saying I'm not
playing in San Diego yeah
it's not Steve Young saying I don't know
because it's the black players that are
getting more control that's why I was
setting you that's why they're this the
black players getting more control in in
it's the it's the stereotype that the
old white earn owners don't have control
of their players anymore that's the
store owner that passed away for the
Houston Texans literally said oh yeah
inmates are running that was finally
yeah that's great and the thing is is
that is probably a prevailing notion
from a lot of people that when the
owners the 32 sit in a room and they go
we need to figure out how to calm these
players to mm-hmm what I think is so
funny is the thing that set off this
conversation was Minka Fitzpatrick
and I'm going you're gonna blame any of
the Miami dollars for trying to trade
like Minka Fitzpatrick Nick Saban called
Minka Fitzpatrick one of his favorite
players that he's ever coached
a leader of a national champion alabama
team we're gonna say that he's selfish
and Miami has the most blatant example
of tanking that we've seen in this sport
maybe ever ever there's no doubt about
that that was the guy that said these
players have too much control yeah if
you want to get upset with a Antonio
Brown I get it but the thing is his NFL
players are hanging around NBA players I
look pregame Todd Gurley kicking it with
montrezl harrell grow up in the same
area there you got they're not we're not
the only people going NFL players were
getting screwed right now - guaranteed
contracts well it's different now it's
just not happening just in football
employees around the world are getting
more control and period you're right we
have made this a sports thing yeah no
employees you talk about entitled man
and that means our minimum wage just
won't have employees around the world
are getting more control the other thing
I think is it's the NFL players saying
you know what not only you know maybe
other owners losing some control but
maybe the players are just getting a
little bit smarter and saying you know
what you need me I've made enough money
and Tonio Brown that I don't necessarily
need this and if you want to treat me
anyway these prey a bad example but then
I'm
I'm not doing it again to me NBA NFL is
hard to ever compare the two because
there's guaranteed contracts in the NBA
and you can say and do whatever the heck
you want are you still getting your
money you got it the NFL is a little bit
different so you got you know a bunch of
these guys 95% of the guys on the team
they need this check yes and they're
gonna want it and there's a possibility
that they're gonna have to get a job
after it so justin pew blew my mind that
i didn't realize that you're getting 17
games or 16 game checks it you're not
getting checks in the offseason no I
never knew that I thought it was like
prorated over 52 weeks now and and just
FYI those playoffs chapstick checks that
you make there for small percentage of
your regular check so you would think
the most important games of your season
that count the most you're probably
getting eight nine thousand but I would
not be able to save money for seven
months
how could to the contract situation a
lot of people are going you know what
it's ruining the NBA it ruined
international soccer where these guys
can hold these franchises hostage and
could this ruin the NFL I would argue
this everyone always looks to stop a
problem
oh these players are getting too much
control right now how do we stop it
to me it's how do you make your
employees happy to where they don't need
to do this yeah they take a negative
approach how do we take power away from
the players my thing is in the NBA they
wanted guys to stay on their small
market teams so they invented bird
rights that's right which was I can
offer you more money than anyone else
can that's right we're now seeing that
it's not enough it's not enough of a gap
to do it but the NFL we haven't even
reached that point right now we had in
the NFL I'm gonna franchise tag you and
I'm giving you the sum of five players
in the NFL but guess what it's not
guaranteed nope so it's really not that
great and I'm preventing you from going
anywhere else and so the NFL the thing
that I'm excited about is we are 18
months away from the CBA
mm-hmm and usually at this time is when
the NFL starts floating out [ __ ] to
distract people we like 18-game
regular-season absolutely
we want to expand this and this and it's
a lot of stuff that the NFL players have
to argue and it distracts them from
getting their main 56% of the pot and
want more here's the thing now I like
the players are going you got to worry
about this [ __ ] right here's the
question do the players really have more
power just Trent Williams have more
power does he because he said he wanted
to be out he's still there
the team still had their little Jordan
know yeah okay listen if they have more
power why is he still unemployed well he
still has a job but he's not getting
paid no he's lying [ __ ] William losing
money he's he
I believe Jeff Williams is closer to
coming back than anyone cuz he's saying
okay how much is that every week 1.2 a
girl I gotta come out of my own pocket
yeah to pay this not money that I'm
getting for the season
Colin Kaepernick can't even you know but
but here's the thing so to me the team's
still have the power that they have the
decision to say no no you sit until we
pay you
same thing with that you know to keep
playing and we'll figure the contract
out the team has that power they have
that ability now there's a team one is
saying you know what maker we're not
trading you you're just gonna play with
us or don't play at all that's what they
said to Melvin Gordon oh you know what
um Antonio Brown we're not trading you
either play with us or don't play at all
that's what the team's could say but
what they was chosen to say is hey to
your point they're throwing out whatever
all they have all the power and now they
demanded a trade well I'm part of the
negotiation is saying okay well if you
don't want to pay me allow someone else
to pay me that's the only leverage as a
player has yeah
so yeah in a way we've taken a few
examples of players getting traded
that's right and we've created this
narrative that the player has got all
the power really no they don't have the
power because you don't have a power
unless you're Contractors guarantee
whether I'm getting so if I can say I'm
getting my money regardless I don't care
if y'all make me sit down or not then
then then you have no power if you have
power that you can say you're gonna
trade me whether you like it or not in
the truth is that Trent Williams he
wants to get traded they said no we're
not training you sit down until you want
to come back to
us or nobody else same thing with Melvin
Gordon they don't have the power these
other guys they've changed things around
I think Jalen Ramsey and said you know
what I don't want to be here no more I
want to go somewhere else but that
doesn't mean that they're gonna try them
guess what's gonna happen this week he's
gonna play for the Jaguars this week and
they're gonna try to figure something
out
but if these teams were not rebuilding
or we're not very good football teams
then they would be like no we're gonna
keep you because we need you quickly on
the Jalen Ramsey thing I got hit up on
Instagram by my guide to bearded dragon
AKA lance blair and he said man you got
to take a look at some of this stuff and
i tweeted it out it is interesting that
the Lions released CJ Anderson and Josh
Johnson yeah their GM as Bob Quinn used
to be under Bill Belichick secretly
they've built up about 17 million
dollars in capra Diana Rossini has
reported that one NFC team has off
excuse me Oh has offered a first-round
pick and a fifth round pick and Jalen
Ramsey liked a post on Instagram of a
Detroit Lions fan that said Lions we've
had a lot of great 20s in our life no
way here he Simsbury sin I'm just saying
though that if you have Matt Patricia
mm-hmm who Mike Daniels came out earlier
this offseason and said he's an
incredible defensive mind right
they have Trey flowers Mike Daniels a
Sean Roberts all those guys our front
and your corners can be Darius slay
yeah and Jalen Ramsey it's not a bad
situation I think it's a bad situation
because you can't win all pensively in
that league with that team that you have
yeah that's why it's a bad situation to
me again that Stanford's better than
Donovan now you better get out of here
here's the truth if I'm Jalen Ramsey
again you're the best you're the best
extra position yes do you have an
opportunity to choose kind of exactly
where you want to go but a I know I
don't want to go there I don't want to
go any losses the Jaguars have right now
I'm in - yeah how many losses the Lions
have right now zero okay I'm with you
they've also played different teams so I
mean of course of course
big time you do the Chargers I think the
Jaguars would beat the Lions you near a
statistic about how amazing Jalen Ramsay
is sure and by the way the Lions would
beat the [ __ ] out of jurors I don't they
play I'll bet you on it what would have
you based dad what are you talking what
the Lions might beat the Eagles this
weekend you probably need to get your
head checked
jaelyn Ramsay was targeted a hundred and
twenty times while covering Antonio
Brown T Y Hilton Tyree kill Odell and
DeAndre Hopkins the passer rating
against him was a was 69 yeah nice rest
to the NFL quarterbacks allowed a 104
rating when covering that group also
Jalen Ramsey is the only quarterback
that's faced 300 targets or more in the
NFL and allowed a negative EPA per
target which means the offense was
actually worse per play when target he's
the only cornerback in the entire NFL
you know I had to hurry I heard a bunch
of people on TV talking about this and
they were like well no I wouldn't give
up two first-round picks for a
cornerback because defensive linemen are
way more important to quarterbacks and
I'm like what do a defensive lineman a
you have much more impact on the game
well tell me this if I could take away
your best player if I could take away
Antonia Brown I could take away a
Hopkins I can take away Davante Adams
you gotta throw it to your second or
third best player I'll let my second
tier defensive lineman get there you
know how I know that's [ __ ] let's
look at the smartest football mind in
maybe the history of the game Bill
Belichick ur name one defensive lineman
that he's paid in his entire time he's
got rid of him Richard was a Richard
Seymour went to okay how about the guy
it's the big guy in the middle ray
flowers was on his team of there got a
big but you know who he has paid monster
contract to Stephon Gilmore monster
contracted Darrelle Revis he pays one
position he gave a monster contract to a
safety yeah Devin McCourty he does not
pay defensive lineman my thoughts about
football I'm just gonna copy Bill
Belichick that would be a good start
wwbd
if you do you have a great start tossing
him but listen Jamie Ramsey is a
generational talent at that cornerback
position but if he goes to Lyons you
heard of her first
no he's not gonna lies he has to go to a
contender how about you a dollar here's
the thing he has to go to a contender he
should go to a contender he should want
to go to a contender he shouldn't go to
a real situation as I get to choose yeah
I know he doesn't give us all the power
the team offers the best deal we'll get
I say 100
once he can't want to go to Detroit
really that's what you want to go
Detroit come on come on not Detroit go
to a team that can win if Kansas City is
even in the mix I'm going to Kansas City
if the Eagles are in the mix I'm going
to the eat yeah but you know what though
when a team is scorned and a player
publicly says I don't want to play for
you we're gonna [ __ ] send in you in
the conference today as a city I'm
sending you to a place that is openly
mocked about living there I [ __ ] with
Detroit everyone that shits on it I
think it's messed up Detroiters is one
of my favorite show yeah but you should
watch it's hilarious but Jacksonville is
gonna go
oh we're sending you the AFC North and
Yakko play Aaron Rodgers and and go I'm
with you all right so let's view quick
games that we that we really like I want
to start with the game of the weekend
Ravens
Chiefs love it love it because sure
what's your initial feeling about this
cool Chiefs are favored by six and a
half as we've seen the Ravens against
Miami in Arizona and the question has to
be is a level of competition that that's
the truth when I saw column early Mary
put up 300 plus yards
yes almost 350 100 350 yards against
this raven defense so so the question is
how good are the Ravens your Super Bowl
squabbles is an error in judgment now
where the Patriots win the Super Bowl
for the earth well good we don't stop
talking about the Ravens they're so low
the Ravens this is this is the question
I'm just checking dirt they're on the
road they're going against a team that
you know can score but a defense that
you should be able to be successful in
here's the big question and I think this
is one of the things that nobody ever
thinks about but the truth is this when
you have an offense like the Chiefs you
know they're putting a point so now
three points it's not an option there's
not an option for Lamar Jackson in that
debt offensive squad and Mark Ingram
it's not an option for Mark Andrews and
John Harbaugh and those guys in Gregg
room it's not an option the only option
is we got us get deep enough that we can
score touchdowns that puts pressure a
different type of pressure on Lamar
Jackson that he didn't have when he
played against Miami and the Cardinals
now the only thing I'm gonna say to that
is Baltimore right now they've gone for
three four fourth downs
Baltimore is one of the more aggressive
teams because I agree with you yeah like
what
son of Oakland last week is when you're
playing Kansas City you go we have to
get this fourth down because they're
gonna eat the ball back not only the
fourth there but you call plays
differently because you know what I
gotta take a shot here you do it's the
number one special teams the NFL's you
know Baltimore I'm not surprised about
that
John Harbor was one of the best special
team coaches in the NFL I I agree with
you as a Baltimore stand my biggest fear
is that Miami had success with multiple
wide receivers and Arizona had success
and that's what Kansas City does and the
question for Baltimore is going to be
can they control the clock can they keep
long drives put them together and if
mahomes gets it because they're kind of
a burst offense yeah keep them in a
field try try and ruin their rhythm a
little bit the one thing that Baltimore
has to do to even be in this game
touchdowns versus field goals their
defense I think it's acceptable because
we saw that last week yes what the
rookie quarterback touchdowns versus
field goes if you know obviously they're
personally the red zone trips to be it's
a different world and so to me that also
means that we're gonna still see some
more running like we saw last week from
tomorrow Jackson because there's gonna
be situations where they have everyone
covered he's gonna have to run the
football I I don't have a problem with
that I just think that you have to
understand going into the game you might
see a bunch of that it's weird to see a
Baltimore Ravens offense and obviously
you have to consider their opponent
they're number one in the league in
point which is crazy it's crazy to see
that our guy warren sharp who you
haven't had a chance to meet is i've
read a lot of his stuff sharpen sharp
guy brewing again literally yeah he had
this nugget two days ago about patrick
mahomes all of his red zone passes the
ones that have been graded successful so
it means like good throw in the right
location
23% number 27 the NFL last year it was
52% he was number one in the NFL she's
were the number one red zone offense
last year currently 27 that I agree with
you completely if the Chiefs get down to
the red zone and the Ravens are able to
I could see them playing kind of a
prevent defense until they get down
there if they're able to hold on to
field goals because the advantage the
Ravens have they might turn a trip
that's a punt for most teams yes into a
55 yard Justin Tucker field over and
so Rhett if if in the first half this is
for my in-game betters you see the
Chiefs kind of struggling in the red
zone a little bit of this games could be
really close
i I don't think it's gonna be a blowout
by any means but I I want to see against
better competition how good Lamar
Jackson a hundred percent agree that's
the dusty the biggest question to me of
the entire week of all the games is how
good is Lamar Jackson really against
another team that has a little bit
better deenis maybe but it's certainly
an office that can go right back at you
just I'm letting you know I'm putting
$50 on in myoma money on Baltimore money
line because red 3:7 really exactly yeah
I could be talked into a lot no I
originally came out at four and a half
and on the weekend I went to six and a
half which means yeah to me it feels
like a cheese 4.1 in my mind and this is
and when the Lions going up like that
there's a feeling that it make it it
make it to ten nothing to lies gonna do
but they may they may win by let's say
seven to ten you know about another
dollar on are we doing the line seven
points so you cheese at the win by seven
I'll take it
okay that's I guess two dollars what was
our first bet I can't remote jail and
Ramsey's Alliance let's quickly do just
two other games I just want your take
I'm not gonna talk at All Saints
Seahawks yeah
Teddy Bridgewater having to go to
Seattle where as I've told you guys
before in the last 16 games that Seattle
has played at home in September there 16
and no so what do you think about this
game can Teddy get it going I don't know
and what's your take i I'm say this I
think is gonna be tough sledding for a
teddy I think that he's limited as far
as his velocity or throwing the ball
down the field I think he's pretty
accurate on a short stuff but to me a
different angle that I would like to
look at it from is will they ever get
this running game going a little bit to
support their quarterback and do they
actually want to do that with Alvin
Kamara latavius married to me has just
been just a guy opposed to what Mark
Mark Ingram was that that punch in the
mouth
sledgehammer would give him 20 carries
we know he's gonna get close to 100
yards let's say miss Mary's not that guy
do you can't you depend on Alva chimera
to be that guy only 26 carries on the
season to me this is the stat that is
crazy only eight catches he's one of
your best receiver he's your second-best
receiver out there Mike Thomas what why
why only he only has eight catches
especially when your quarterback is not
throwing the ball down the field
especially with Teddy played most of the
game last week well I don't see only
have eight that to me that doesn't make
any sense I remember last year I was
like oh my god they're gonna kill this
kid the first four games of the season
Mark Ingram wasn't there yeah and they
just gave him ball at the ball that's 15
targets one game 12 targets and next
they were given the football to me
what's gonna happen with Teddy how good
can Teddy be I don't think they win the
football game but I think it's a good
test to kind of see where they're gonna
end up at really even in their own
division Sean not the conference but if
division came out today and said both
Teddy and Taysom Hill will be playing
quarterback on son I believe that III
don't think that there's gonna be a
situation where you're solely tied in
just to Teddy I think that if if Teddy
struggles for a couple series I wouldn't
I wouldn't put it past Sean Peyton
pudding tastes a meal and this is my one
note to think about the amount of times
that drew brees on third down would add
about to a better play or get low behind
the line and do a hot route to extend a
drive drew Brees was amazing at finding
a mismatch on third and short and
extending a drive the thing I want to
watch is how much more tired is the
Saints defense going to get if Teddy can
extend these drugs because I believe the
Saints are built a lot like the Chiefs
which is we have an offense that we
believe can get out to elite escort
that's why we traded up to get Marcus
Davenport and we believe in cam Jordan
and we can take a little bit of risk
because you need to be risky to keep up
with us but if now we're gonna get into
a possession game
I find that Saints defense to be a
little bit shallow I don't see a lot of
depth well they have series over the
season how that changes our Drew Brees
this is an important point there at
Seattle they have Dallas Tampa Bay which
i think is a questionable game from some
of the Saints at Jacksonville probably
Ramsey is gone by them who knows was
Jacksonville may have poles back at
Chicago then they have Arizona to me
when I look at those next six gangs they
may be tuned for its wild that gets ugly
for the things the other game that we
want to talk about quickly Rams at
Browns yeah you think that this could
get ugly for the Browns I think you
could I think they I think they lose a
game but I think the aftermath they had
a terrible loss first week they came
back the second week and played a little
bit better but not everyone's talking
about the Odell touchdown but overall
struggling against the defense that
didn't have couldn't Williams or average
there here's a big step for the failure
didn't look good at all big step for the
for the Browns there are five of 23 on
third down right there negative three
turnover ratio ratio right and Baker is
he has two touchdowns and four
interceptions
you can't win playing football like that
you can't consistently win you can win
and beat the the bad teams you can't
consistently win now what happens to a
team there was my biggest fear about
this this Browns team all season what
happens if you win a couple games how
does that swagger good get to be too
much and what happens if you lose a
couple and what happens when the fingers
start to point and what happens when you
have so many personalities and then
everybody wants to be the leader and
help us get out of here and now I got to
tell you to shut the F up because I'm
the leader what happens then I think you
could get ugly for the the Browns if
they lose this game bad it can get
really ugly my prediction is on Sunday
we're gonna look and we're gonna go
Patrick mahomes Lamar Jackson that's the
future of the NFL and then we're gonna
look at Jared Goff on the road and Baker
Mayfield and we're gonna go this was
supposed to be the future of the NFL and
we're all gonna sit there and we're
gonna find a way to not talk about it
yeah but I'm telling you on Sunday Lamar
and Patrick are gonna look like the
future and Jared Goff and Baker Mayfield
people are gonna go this doesn't look
right and that's not what people would
have thought in the beginning of the
year you wouldn't have thought that last
week today was a good conversation not
really hitting me hard it's an
aggressive because you're not giving me
50% if you would give me 50% I don't
have to go as hard if you're back there
I got a thin oh and I took this matcha
class nice arms
you did I did it was great second time
second time there 45 minutes for
everyone out there that's afraid of
exercising Brian Westbrook literally
before the workout was like I'm gonna go
in there I'm gonna be slow and I'm like
[ __ ] Westbrook special I hate work
you know he absolutely hate it my wife
threw me out of the door it forced me to
go there like yesterday I got fat shamed
last night vision Pinkberry oh yeah
really cuz apparently I make noises when
I eat uh-huh you're a moaner like me and
she was like stop being fat that is a
greedy greedy man trait also like when I
probably you loved every taste that my
kids do that I hate it you're right your
wife should make your fiance should make
fun of you all right homies enjoy the
games again coming out Friday
Warren Sharpe betting podcast we're
gonna try and make some money I've been
making betting all Warren's bets man
they're coming up roses
Westbrook you're the [ __ ] man did
enjoyed it man make sure you go to my
website be Westbrook calm I forgot all
about bu Westbrook duck w @ w es TBR
double okay here it is and I am the lef
koe man college letter these guys
[Music]